we got a prop that was designed for the
artists that we could become they were
the poi that everyone wanted to have
they were fashionable flexible and the
design was so beautiful that they felt
like a product made to make us look good
it was the perfect product at the
perfect time drex here from
drexfactorpoi sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flowers to benefit
your body and brain in this video i want
to talk about a product that's become so
ubiquitous that i think we sometimes
forget just how important it was it's
the 10-year anniversary of podpoi and
i'm marking the occasion by talking
about pod poise place in history and in
my own personal flow journey before we
dive in though i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission
2012 was the year that podpoi descended
upon the flow world and things would
never be the same again pod poi are a
brand of led poi from emeryville
california-based prop maker's flow toys
and i actually still have my original
set of pod poi right here they gave me
these a decade ago and i can still
remember how excited i was to get them
to understand why though it's probably
helpful to put them in the context of
flow arts history for a moment i
definitely think of poi spinning as
having had an era before and after the
release of pod poi before their release
there were certainly other options for
led poi but all of them came with some
pretty heavy caveats my very first led
poi were from home of poi and they were
more than a little shall we say
delicate i'd usually go through a set of
these every few months i'd add split
rings to the little silicone tabs
because if you connected those tabs
directly to the tether they'd split open
in just a couple weeks
in addition the batteries had a short
life span and the switch would tend to
fail after a couple months i remember
using tinfoil to try and bridge the
contacts and give them a little bit more
life but really when that switch started
to fail it was just a matter of time so
led props certainly existed but were
they durable dependable or even much to
look at
in most cases the answer was decidedly
no but flow toys started to sow the
seeds of the revolution to come when
they introduced their first
flow lights
these were small modular led capsules
that used aaa batteries and came in a
variety of different options they were
also incredibly collectible flowtoys
would release different color
combinations under the name water air
spirit watermelon and many more some of
us would get into the habit of picking
up the new color drops when they
happened for a while it was fashionable
to attach the color of your choice to
your belt at flow festivals to make it
easier for your friends to track you
down in the dark this by the way is
still a first edition water one and you
will take this out of my cold dead hands
but as awesome as the flow lights were
they also had a few major drawbacks for
one there was programmability really you
could only control their strobing
pattern and if you wanted different
colors you'd have to buy an entirely new
flowlight it was also becoming more and
more clear that the world of electronics
was moving toward devices that would
house proprietary batteries that could
recharge via micro usb
next the flow lights were a major
innovation in durability but it came
with a massive catch i don't think i
ever managed to actually break one but
their polycarbonate housing could be
very unforgiving they would hurt if they
hit you at top speed and that happened a
lot if you were just starting out on
your poi journey finally the poi world
had begun its migration towards contact
poi becoming the form factor of choice
rather than having long narrow form
factors similar to glow sticks poi was
becoming increasingly knobby with the
mass centered in a round head podpoi
represented a massive step forward in
all of these departments the form factor
was teardrop shaped and while the
capsules inside remain locked up tight
behind a durable polycarbonate shell the
housing for them was silicone and it had
a large amount of flexible internal
volume that absorbs impacts
they shifted the mass to the end of the
head fitting in perfectly with the new
generation of tech poi tricks that
focused momentum and attention on the
activity of the head they were also the
first truly programmable full spectrum
led poi that i ever used each individual
mode could be modified by holding down
the single button interface and letting
the poi cycle through options available
for that mode you could cycle through
different colors patterns or palettes
for each mode and of course they
maintain flowtoys's legendary modularity
the capsules could be put in the ends of
poi staffs rope darts you name it many
of us would collect the different
modular prop attachments on principle
alone just so we'd have the option of
having that other prop setting around if
we wanted to play with it but the
flagship for these products was
absolutely the poi and pod poi in
themselves would take the flow world by
storm
not only did the first batch sell out in
only six hours the next two batches both
sold out within a day as well it was the
perfect product at the perfect time so
why was that it can't be overstated just
how flexible they really were it should
tell you something that i still have my
first set of pod poi all these years
later no matter what other form factors
or manufacturers i played with pod poi
were always kind of a home base that you
could return to either by yourself or
with others that were well suited to
just about any types of tricks whether
they be beginner or tech and they
weren't just flexible they were
accessible i remember a couple other
people who beta tested these complaining
about how light they were without
realizing that that was a feature rather
than a bug lighter poi are more
forgiving when you're starting out to
say nothing of being more accessible to
younger spinners and those with physical
disabilities before this there had never
really been a product that was anything
close to an industry standard something
that you could whip out and spin with
your friend and know that they'd have
the same ones so you could match it
didn't happen all at once but very
quickly you started to notice other prop
vendors buying them wholesale and
selling them retail they were the poi
that everyone wanted to have they were
fashionable flexible and the design was
so beautiful that they felt like a
product made to make us look good rather
than something hacked together from
off-the-shelf parts and rapidly they
became the standard in the industry
that's actually a much bigger deal than
you may think
there was an entire generation of people
experimenting with partner poi or other
forms of choreography that would either
have to make all their props themselves
or order them in bulk from a supplier to
make sure they all matched podpoi made
it easy because they were so good for so
many different types of tricks that you
could just about guarantee that everyone
had at least one set can you honestly
tell me you've never encountered them
they're so ubiquitous at this point that
i'd be skeptical i've had multiple sets
over the years and all of them have seen
an enormous amount of use it's actually
kind of funny that this year is the 10
year anniversary of their release
because lately i've been finding myself
using them a lot more than i have in
years a few months ago i had an aha
moment with my poi dance and realized
that lighter poi gave me a broader range
of spinning speeds to work with as i
comb through the poi that i had laying
around to find a set that would be a
good fit for the new style i wanted to
play with
podboy wound up surprising me with just
how well suited they were to the work i
was doing with capsules 2.0 podpoi
extended their programming capabilities
gave us many more options for how these
leds could show off our own unique style
and added wireless control
recently smithy rope and now fpc have
become standard options updating this
design for a whole new generation of poi
spinners i think it says a lot that in a
decade the biggest improvements have
been made to the software of these poi
the design was such a home run upon
dropping that there's been little need
to update it since 2012. with pod poi we
got a prop that was designed for the
artists that we could become it was a
serious product for a dedicated
subculture and something so well
engineered that it could be used for
just about all of the myriad styles of
poi that branched out in the intervening
years with flowtoyz's warranty program
it's also been a sterling example of
both environmental stewardship and
customer service
these aren't just disposable plastic
trinkets destined to clog up our
landfills and waterways they are
sustainably produced and it's important
to flow toys that they be updated
regularly without becoming a drain on
our waste management systems they are
our standard product for a reason end to
end they were created with smart choices
and an eye toward being just as useful
to the experts as they were to beginners
10 years later they're also still
surprising me with how well they can
support my flow and my experimentation
so
happy 10 years young to the venerable
pod poi and here's to many more to come
can't wait to spend with you some more
old friend what are your favorite
memories of pod poi leave me a comment
and let me know when you got your first
set and what you remember about your
first time spinning them
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helped make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to try and bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
bodies and their brains so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you if you dug
this video you might be interested in
checking out some of my equipment
reviews for led poi and a variety of
other flow arts props i'll leave a link
to a playlist of these videos down in
the description as well as up on screen
if you are watching on youtube
please make sure to get out and flow
today reconnect with your own old and
beloved props and i'll see you with a
new video on wednesday
thanks for watching and have a good one
peace